We wouldn’t be where we are at Google without
you, the developer community.
Since 2005, we’ve made dozens of APIs and
tools available to you, then you went out
and built marvels.
Now, with so many creations, we think there’s
a better way for them to work together, because...
there are a lot.
So we did some spring cleaning, then asked
you how we could do it better.
We used your ideas to begin building a single
place for all of the developer resources,
tools, events, and community.
And all of that together looks like this:
developers.google.com
But it’s more than just a logo.
It’s a symbol for all the amazing work you
do in the world and how you work together.
Soon you can find tools, get ideas, and connect
with others, all in one place.
Then, get down to business.
Collaboration and coding power that creates
magical solutions with a universal language.
So you can take that mass of code and blow
minds.
For reals.
So kick off your shoes and explore all the
ways you can connect.
Because it’s not just about code, it’s
about you.
Then, start building.
Because together, there’s no telling what
we’ll create next.
developers.google.com